(whooshes)
(soft music)
- I hate hugging.
- I love hugging.
- I felt like that was coming.
- Sometimes I love hugs
more than breathing.
- If it was up to me I'd
greet everyone with a hug.
- Unless it's somebody I know really well,
it's always made me like
really uncomfortable.
- I love hugging.
(laughs)
- I hate hugging.
- Oh really?
- I'm so sorry.
- Do I like have to make eye contact
with Jameson as I hug him?
- No.
What?
- Do people do that?
I don't know.
- Oh God.
The moment.
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] Just take it all in.
- Yeah I'm taking it in.
- Oh we got ears touching.
- We just stand here like this?
I'm hyper aware of all or the parts
of our bodies that are toughing.
(giggles)
- You're like whimpering.
It's okay Kevin.
- Don't do that.
- Your hearts beating very fast.
- I know because I'm hugging.
(laughter)
(peppy music)
- There you go,
as he almost falls backwards.
- I feel like we're more
friends than we'd have been
if we stood here for 20 seconds not like,
- yeah.
- Just like hanging out.
- You don't normally hug people for more
than like maybe even three seconds,
so the fact that we did it 20 seconds
kind of like, created
that sense of we're there
for each other.
- I think people should hug more.
I feel like the world would
be a much better place.
(whooshes)